bonsoir francis bacon merci d'être venu
ici au bas je crois que vous connaissiez
vous connaissez cette boîte de nuit
avant malheureusement pas non
aller à terme en intéressant vraiment je
voulais venir vous avez votre chef oui
c'est ça très fier vous allez au palace
à l'époque de fabrice oui je suis allé
deux trois fois parce que j'ai connu pas
la bri
un peu et
voilà mes cd terme en schiste quelle
farce jusqu'à arriver à lui mais sa vie
est tellement dur n'est ce pas je
travaille toute la nuit dans l'es2 avec
ton et de boîtes mais oui c'est un homme
de la nuit mais vous aussi vous êtes un
homme de la nuit vous travaillez là même
la nuit
vous travaillez la nuit où vous allez
dans les moeurs je gère d'habitude je
suis dans les bars et parce que je
trouvais très bonne heure le matin je me
lève de contribuer à la lumière et je
commence à ces moments du travail
j'ai jusqu'à minuit à midi ou à une
heure et puis je dresse la journée pour
moi pour boire et pour faciliter avec
les autres et vous avez bien boire
qu'est ce que ça vous apporte livre est
une journée non je savais je sais tu
investis en élite on est libre alors
qu'est ce que vous voulez il veut il
vaut mieux vivre pour oublier la réalité
ou
quoi pas parce qu'en fait donc dans vos
tableaux dans votre peinture on va
compter c'est un peu la solitude la mort
la difficulté d'être le quai lequel elle
vous préférez la réalité ou le ou la
cruauté de votre peinture parce que
c'est un monde en fait
traduction mais lundi et qu elle est si
basse plus cruel que vos peintures
beaucoup plus clair et on on sait
vraiment quand on part de ce côté de moi
tu faut penser à la vie et on passe la
vie bras dessus bras dessous avec
l'homme avec la mort la mort nous
accompagne toujours
et dans vos dents au tableau vous pour
vous peignez essentiellement des
portraits
quels sont les très souvent les gens
sont beaux et quand une fois pain ici
deviennent les quelle est la vôtre
notion de la laideur et de la beauté
cela s'est par la même chose bien sûr
mais d'habitude je fais la portée des
gens que je connais bien parce que et
gens j'aime voile et les gens beaux mais
temps en travaillant on est
on les fait souvent l'est parce que ça
marche pas mieux dans
dans le sens de la vie les deux sens de
l'esthétique
ça m'a souvent mieux parce qu'il faut
des formes et la vie pour leur donner
pour vous rattraper la réalité déformée
lundi pour nous pour mieux la retrouver
oui vous êtes aujourd'hui sans doute le
plus grand peintre vivant au jeu
confirmé cette question savez ça passe
tellement vite il est allé moment voilà
en deux trois jours en trouver un autre
quand quand un groupe est niée il
pleurait très souvent avant d'attaquer
un tableau surtout quand c'était un
portrait alors vous vous peignez
essentiellement des portraits
est-ce que vous avez ce sentiment de
danger de mort quand vous peignez c'est
pâques en semaine il y en a toujours et
toujours on sait toujours tout près à la
mort quand on est très jeune en pense
pas cette chose là mais avec l'âge savez
ça forcément ça c'est et puis on dit en
guise en collant boisson vous avez
commencé à peindre en fait assez tard
vers l'âge de 30 ans oui c'est ça qu'est
ce que vous faisiez avant avant je pense
à vous et il va dire 60 de oui j'étais
dans les temps changent pas tous quand
j'avais un peu il y avait un temps
j'avais un peu la gent
je m'amuse récemment pendant j'avais pas
envie rien faire vous aimiez le jeu je
crois non j'adore le jeu parce que de
temps en temps ça m'a beaucoup aidé mais
vous savez à la fin et perdu j'ai perdu
beaucoup mais je veux encore poker non
je jouais là-bas
le jeu a le plus belge monde à olette
parce que c'est seulement là où je jette
souvent gagné vous avez un numéro ou
plusieurs numéros favoris parle pas tout
à fait mais bon ça change aujourd'hui de
jouer encore oui je pense que vous savez
maintenant à londres on peut jouer là il
y attend de casino par tout ça vous
convient à une toile de francis bacon
jaune
comment une toile vous combien on peu
près à 100 je sais pas parce que c'est
ce que la carie me donne et c'est ce qui
est à quel prix et les vents moi je sais
pas non est ce que vous vous souhaitez
que vos oeuvres soit dans un musée bacon
après un après goût est ce la bonne
fondation noms font pire sinon je n'aime
pas toutes ses sondes version qu'un
conte à caen a fait maintenant on peu
partout ça vous gêne pas que ce soient
éparpillés
comment que ça vous gêne pas qu'il y en
ait un peu partout dans tous les pays du
monde
un collectionneur n'ai pas envie de voir
ça quelque part vous amuser mes canons
c'est quoi la vie d'un tableau une fois
que vous l'avez fini l'idéal pour vous
c'est quoi que tu ne t'appelles sa part
je sache vous aurez pas de chez moi
et voilà j'en vois tout de suite à la
galerie et voici le pont levant est pas
souvent posé mes tableaux sont toujours
très difficiles avant quel est votre
votre production peut ni combien de
tableau par semaine par semaine
oui non je ne vais pas vous savez prat
semaine par mois soit moins parents ou
sa part peut-être avec ses deux hôtes
war cette quantité qu peut-être 200 et
là les vingt toiles sont exposées à la
galerie lelong en rut et rend à paris
son seul travail le fruit de combien de
deux ans
oui mais ce qui est curieux dans votre
peinture c'est depuis le début depuis
les premières qu'aussi fiction 1943
quelque chose comme ça jouera jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est toujours le même
travail la même obsession on retrouve
notamment l'obsession du sens là qui est
concrétisé par une toile ou seulement
une tâche de sang
vous avez quand j'ai fait la crucifixion
cette part parce que je ne suis pas du
tout religieux mais il est on avait des
crises fiction qui m'a beaucoup touché
comme l'école par télé
c'est un autre le team à boué et les
gens comme ça mais c'était alors à cette
époque là quand j'ai commencé je n'avais
pas vraiment un sujet alors sept à cause
de ses tableaux que j'aime énormément
les gaules vague et je ma peau et que
j'ai commencé avec les crucifixions mais
c'est pas parce que je suis religieux
que j'avais les glandes fiction c'était
un test un sujet et qu'est ce qui a
déclenché en fait votre goût pour la
peinture votre attirance pour la
peinture comme vous êtes dit je vais
devenir peintre
c'est une exposition picasso à paris en
ce sens j'ai vu oui j'ai vu une
exclusion par un picasso s'est hissée
rosenberg à cette époque là je vois
c'est même par les pelles et picasso que
je préfère mais en même temps je pensais
à pourquoi je peux pas essayer vers la
peinture visé cet ambitieux ambitieux
oui et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
1 pouces bleus